if you plan on going into Avengers end
game completely spoiler free well best
of luck to you
but if you really just can't wait for
your next endgame fix these leaks and
spoilers should tide you over until
April sometimes it isn't what a Marvel
actor says that gives the game away but
where they say it in August 2000 a teen
fans notice that a certain
behind-the-scenes interview with Robert
Downey jr. seemed to take place on the
set of sharie's lab and Wakanda taking
this at face value it would seem to
imply that Tony Stark is going to a
condom and could meet the young wakandan
genius herself the second endgame
trailer revealed what we all knew was
going to happen Tony Stark makes it back
to earth once home it looks like he and
Cherie could combine their considerable
brainpower and scientific know-how to
give the Avengers a chance to put things
right
unfortunately Marvel threw a curveball
during the endgame trailer by having
Cherie space flash up on one of Bruce
banners monitors implying that she was
lost during the decimation this is
despite Angela Bassett who plays Queen
Ramona having already confirmed a Screen
Rant that she and Cherie both survived
obviously Thanos will return an endgame
but will he really be the lead villain
long before Avengers 4 had even been
given a title tie-in mergeformatinet
[Music]
racoon kitted out with brand-new
matching costumes included a short
synopsis that seemingly confirmed a new
villain would come to the fore in
endgame it read the Asgardian Thor
wields the mighty storm breaker in his
battle against new foes
rocket teams up with a new crew to guard
the galaxy from an even greater threat
how the hell I don't got that long a
lifespan anyway but who or what could
this greater threat be if end game
follows the plots of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic Nebula could end up as
the main antagonist but there are a
whole host of other villains who could
end up facing down the Avengers of
course it's entirely possible that
Thanos is the primary villain for
endgame after all and that this greater
threat is a terrifying new plan that
he's putting into action who knows in
October 2018 The Wrap exclusively
revealed that 13 reasons why star
Kathryn Langford had joined the cast of
the upcoming Avengers sequel in a
mystery role and various other media
outlets quickly back the story up The
Hollywood Reporter later confirmed
Langford has filmed scenes for the
currently untitled Avengers for
character details were not available and
Marvel Studios had no comment
movie web sources claim that Langford
had already finished up all of her
filming for the movie suggesting that
she was brought on board in a relatively
minor role and did what she needed to do
during the September 2018 reshoots
so Langford spark probably won't be a
big one but if it was a little more than
glorified extra work then Marvel
wouldn't have gone to the trouble of
hiring an in-demand star she got a
much-deserved not at the Golden Globes
2018 for her work as Hannah Baker in
teen drama 13 reasons why the first
season of which was a massive hit for
Netflix Marvel and Disney clearly know a
rising star when they see one but just
how important Langford is the end game
has yet to be seen Don Cheadle's Colonel
James Rhodes was badly injured during
the events of Captain America Civil War
but Tony Stark's loyal Air Force buddy
came back from the brink of paralysis to
join the fight against Thanos and
infinity war rody was one of the few
heroes who survived the mad Titans mass
genocide in that movie meaning he'll be
among those who rally against the bill
in an end game and he'll apparently be
doing so in some badass new armor boom
you looking for this
toy related leaks have been coming thick
and fast as endgames release draws ever
closer
and while the Russo brothers have
insisted that the vast majority of these
toys are not reflective of the movies
actual plot the sibling directors have
been known to tell little white lies in
order to throw fans off the scent images
of what appear to be official endgame
LEGO sets are now online and there's
every reason to believe they're the real
deal
one set that is already being sold in
the UK is titled war machine Buster as
the name suggests it's a Hulkbuster
style version of Rody's war machine
armor this isn't official confirmation
that will see Rhodey and new pimped-out
armor during endgame but the fact that
the set also includes war machine and
ant-man minifigures suggests we might
indeed since the two characters have
shown suiting up side by side and end
games Super Bowl TV spots
despite starring in 2011's Thor and its
2013 follow-up Thor the dark world
Natalie Portman's Jane Foster was
nowhere to be seen in the trilogy's
wildly successful threequel Thor
Ragnarok sorry I hear that Jane dumped
you she didn't dump me though dumped us
the mutual dumping Portman is said to
have fallen out of love with Marvel
Studios during the course of the
much-maligned the dark world displeased
that future Wonder Woman director patty
Jenkins was let go from the project but
Marvel has changed since then and so has
Portman stance on the franchise when she
spoke to Screen Rant in early 2018
the Oscar winner revealed that she was
actually open to reap rising the role in
future movies though she hadn't heard
anything from Marvel at that time it
seems the Russo brothers got this
message loud and clear because when they
were asked about Foster's status post
decimation by the huffington post a few
months later they refused to comment
because it was a potential spoiler
implying that the studio may still have
plans for the character going forward of
course Foster is one of the MCS leading
astrophysicist so her skillset would
certainly come in handy during endgame
but if nothing else Jane and Thor could
probably do with morale boost after the
events of infinity war
reunion could be just the thing they
need check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Avengers endgame are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]